m
décembre 2015 paris capitale du monde
accueille la coop 21 plus de 150 chefs
d'état et de gouvernement sont réunis
pour obtenir un accord historique sur le
climat et limiter la hausse globale des
températures en dessous des 2 degrés
celsius
il s'agit de décider ici à paris de
l'avenir même de la planète
mais dans cette négociation entre chefs
d'état quel peut être le rôle des
parlementaires
vous allez voir comment trois sénateurs
ont tenté d'imprimer leur marque sur ce
sommet parfois en pleine lumière souvent
dans les coulisses ronan dantec connais
par coeur les arcanes des négociations
sur le climat dans cette coop 21
il a troqué son costume de sénateurs
contre celui de porte parole des acteurs
non étatiques m'a bien compris que les
engagements des états ne suffisait pas
si on a pas de dynamique des acteurs les
collectivités les entreprises l'ensemble
des ong
on a en érigent force il a deux
objectifs dans cette conférence lancé le
sommet de nantes 2 septembre 2016
réunissant la société civile mais aussi
faire reconnaître ses acteurs dans
l'accord final de la cap 21
hervé maurey et président de la
commission du développement durable du
sénat et jérôme bignon président du
groupe de travail pour les négociations
internationales sur le climat
eux sont venus défendre le rôle des
parlementaires dans cette coop autant
dans la négociation elle même
le parlement a souvent le sentiment
d'être un peu exclu parce que c'est les
gouvernements qui négocie on entend dans
l'application un accord le parlement et
le sénat ont et auront un rôle très
important
car une fois l'accord ratifié par les
états 7 aux parlements nationaux de le
transposer dans leur droit et de
l'adopter faute de quoi il n'a aucune
valeur prendre des objectifs si on les
intègre pas à la fois dans la
législation et à la fois dans les
budgets
ça n'a pas de sens ça serait en fumée
les populations sur un sujet qui est
sérieux pour eux le point d'orgue c'est
le rassemblement de l'union
interparlementaire à paris en marge de
la coop
leur but faire voter au sénat par les
parlementaires du monde entier un texte
ambitieux sur la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
or la partie
8h30 du matin
nous retrouvons ronan dantec et son
équipe dans le rer direction le bourget
en seine saint denis où se tient la coop
cela fait huit ans qu'il sillonne les
conférences sur le climat
huit ans qu'il se bat pour faire
reconnaître le rôle des acteurs non
étatiques dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
les interlocuteurs les dédales de stands
ses deux salles de réunion il les
connaît par coeur en ce début d'une
négociation
celui qui représente les villes et les
collectivités locales reste prudent on
sait qu'à certains états qui sont encore
très réticents à ce qui est des signes
ont vis-à-vis des acteurs non étatiques
dans les textes de l'accord mais là on
va développer notre ns lobbying dans les
prochains jours un lobbying intensif qui
va durer près de dix jours
rendez-vous réunion consultations
s'enchaînent au pas de course
sous son air débonnaire ronan dantec et
pugnacité martèle son message jusqu en
salle plénière devant les négociateurs
du monde entier
ce mécanisme de coopération des changes
entre état et acteurs non étatiques doit
être à des résultats de l'accord trouvé
l'accord et nous ferons le travail find
the deal we do the job
merci merci les états doivent trouver un
accord pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
une fois l'accord conclu chaque pays
doit le faire ratifier par son parlement
en france le gouvernement devra adapter
le texte sous forme de projet de loi et
le soumettre à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat
en cas de rejet par l'un des parlements
nationaux l'accord mondial ne pourra
s'appliquer
un enjeu crucial pour hervé maurey
président de la commission du
développement durable
c'est lui qui devra suivre le parcours
de ce texte sur le climat au sénat ce
matin pour sa première journée à la cap
il prend ses marques sur le pavillon de
la france au bourget le sénat a eu un
rôle actif dans la préparation de la
coop à travers la mobilisation de la
plupart de ces structures est sûre sur
ce stand on peut justement prendre
connaissance des travaux du sénat donc
je crois que c'est important qu'on se
relâche un objectif partagé par jérôme
bignon sénateurs les républicains et
auteur d'une proposition de résolution
visant à reconnaître le rôle des
collectivités dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
l'urgence est bien là la coop est
probablement un des derniers moments de
l'humanité d'adé dernier moment où
l'humanité est en capacité d'inverser la
tendance
nous sommes dans une période où nous
devons assumer notre responsabilité
climatique
un texte adopté au sénat en novembre
2015 je mets donc aux voix la
proposition de résolution qui et pour
qui et contre 1,6 s'abstient
la proposition de résolution est donc
adopté à l'unanimité
direction l'espace génération climat au
bourget le lieu de rencontre de toute la
société civile collectivités
territoriales entreprises associations
nous retrouvons ronan dantec toujours au
pas de course
ils essaient d'obtenir quelques minutes
avec son principal allié dans cette
négociation
ségolène royal son but faire venir la
ministre de l'ecologie au lancement du
sommet mondial sur le climat des acteurs
non étatiques à nantes en septembre 2016
il a besoin de ce soutien de poids pour
faire reconnaître cette initiative
comment ça va toujours c'est toujours
mais dans cette cohue impossible
d'échanger plus de trois mots ces
négociations de mon point de vue c'est
facebook et speed dating facebook parce
que je cherche en permanence des amis
des gens qui sont suffisamment mes amis
pour porter dans le texte de négociation
nos propositions d'amendements mais
c'est aussi speed dating parce que on a
beaucoup d'acteurs avoir à convaincre
beaucoup d'informations a intégré en
permanence parce que la négociation a
évolué et c'est pour ça que vous voyez
un peu courir dans tous les sens en
permanence ronan dantec pourra-t-il
compter sur la présence de ségolène
royal
le sénateur est encore dans
l'expectative
le lendemain une délégation de sénateurs
en rangs serrés autour de leur président
gérard larcher vient prendre la
température au bourget accueilli par les
deux ministres au de la cap 21
ségolène royal et laurent fabius il en
profite pour se tenir informés de
l'avancée des négociations
mais la négociation
ce qui est le cas d excellence et le
premier jour et je pense qu'on a raison
de faire les chaînes et à goyrans yeux
qui cherche non et ils ont tous dit
messieurs mesdames il faut comme on dit
en anglais délivré maintenant
négociations avec les rythmes donc comme
il doit me donner un premier texte
samedi et mercredi
je vais leur dire ceci est bien
difficile mais mesdames et messieurs
fonctionner pendant ce temps-là ronan
dantec s'apprête à lancer officiellement
son sommet pour le climat à nantes
le climate shens ce rendez-vous de nos
évidemment n'est pas seulement un sommet
c'est un rendez vous mondial annuel que
l'on crée une sorte de coop des acteurs
non étatiques la conférence touche à sa
fin ségolène royal n'est toujours pas là
finalement au dernier moment la ministre
feint la foule et rejoint le sénateur
sur l'estrade pour lui apporter son
soutien
décision des états se réalise à 70% des
niveaux infra étatique
donc c'est dire l'importance des
territoires l importance notamment des
villes
c'est un peu le déjà la fin d'une
première étape de cette coop pour moi
qui étais le lancement du sommet nantais
l'expression commune des acteurs non
étatiques
maintenant on va rentrer dans le texte
sur le texte j'ai quand même toujours
des objectifs donc ça c'est l'étape pour
les prochains jours et pour la semaine
prochaine
une première victoire pour les acteurs
non étatiques au bourget qui sera suivie
d'une seconde
deux jours plus tard en marge de la coop
les maires de près de 700 villes du
monde se réunissent à paris à
l'initiative d'anne hidalgo et de
michael bloomberg ancien maire de new
york un sommet des élus locaux en grande
pompe
nous les villes les régions du monde
nous faisons entendre notre voix ici
dans cette maison pour rappeler qu'elle
que nous sommes partie prenante de ce
destin le du monde
pendant ce temps là au bourget le
marathon des négociations se poursuit
jérôme bignon en vrp du sénat vient
rappeler les engagements déjà pris par
la france en matière de transition
énergétique
bonjour à tous chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs la france a adopté
en août dernier une loi sur la
transition énergétique et la croissance
verte les parlements ont des moyens de
pression sur les gouvernements muzeau
utilisons ces moyens dans l'année à
venir pour garantir le succès de
l'accord de paris je vous remercie
si la langue change le message lui reste
le même sens les parlements nationaux
aucun accord sur le climat ne
s'appliquera
ce soir les acteurs non étatiques sont
de nouveau à l'honneur cette fois au
grand palais à paris dans l'espace des
solutions coop 21
j'ai plus chiant cv aujourd'hui presse
par ans quitte paris
à la soirée d'inauguration ronan dantec
viens de prendre connaissance de la
première ébauche de l'accord sur le
climat
il mesure le chemin qu'il lui reste à
parcourir pour faire passer son message
nous étions 700 maires cet après midi à
la mairie de paris pour dire notre
disponibilité à pour dire notre
engagement au même moment certains
négociateurs supprimer le rôle des
collectivités locales du préambule du
texte y aussi les paradoxes de cette
négociation
on est obligé d'être un petit peu dans
une heure finalement dans une attention
permanente parce que des fois on gagne
des fois on perd sa part dans un sens ou
dans l'autre et la question c'est de
quel côté le balancier s'arrêtera samedi
et à ses torts si je ne peux pas le dire
mais le sénateur n'a pas dit son dernier
mot et martel inlassablement son
objectif
la valse des négociations s'intensifient
difficile d'y voir clair au bourget au
milieu des va et vient incessants dans
les allées hervé maurey et jérôme bignon
viennent chercher les informations à la
source
on voit bien sur ce tableau comment ça
se passe ces négociations vous avez
paragraphe par paragraphe des réunions
spécifiques dans des lieux distinctes et
voilà on négocie grave paragraphe ligne
par ligne
parfois même mot par mot virgule par
virgule
c'est la vraie négociation onusienne va
au même moment ronan dantec et son
équipe passe en revue la dernière
version du texte
il tâte intérêts a juste la stratégie à
adopter dans leur lobbying
chaque fois qu'un mot une virgule change
dans les paragraphes qui les concernent
le but n'est toujours pas apte à faire
reconnaître les acteurs non étatiques
comme ils n'ont pas tranché ça on dit
aux wallons de prendre dialogue et c'est
parce qu'ils prennent dialogue là qui
vont pouvoir justifier qui pèse un peu
les explications qu'on douane si par
hasard vous avez les wallons comme on
maintient dialoguant haut ça justifie de
préciser dans le paragraphe 130 b le
sénateur maîtrise déjà parfaitement le
langage onusien
mais il lui a fallu des années de
pratique c'est incompréhensible tout à
fait en plus beaucoup d'articles font
référence à des articles précédents
la première année où je suis arrivé dans
cette négociation s'est imposé 1 2 me
rappelle encore je vous rappelle des
trois dernières soirées à poznan je ne
comprenais rien y compris voire une
salle qui applaudit parce qu'il ya
marqué à dos petites ailes
un tir et 123 b et que ça crée un
enthousiame dans la salle faut quand
même on met un certain temps à
comprendre si on a pris seule certitude
pour l'instant
ronan dantec n'aura pas la formule qu'il
souhaite dans le préambule
mais pas question de baisser les bras il
va essayer d'obtenir quelques mots dans
le corps du texte sur les moyens
d'action des acteurs non étatiques
nous retrouvons jérôme bignon et hervé
maurey qui enchaîne les conférences de
presse pour comprendre les points de
blocage et anticiper les difficultés
lorsqu'il faudra voter le texte au
parlement français est mort et je suis
clair dans la caution des répondeurs du
sénat avait très bien géré ou millions
donc on a loupé autre point presse elle
va très bien matin 9h30 on en est où la
logan et ça ça mais le stress des
premières
là on bloque sur les points financiers
j'imagine le point bloquant c'est là
c'est la date de première révision des
trois ou cinq ans pour l'instant on
attend juridique face à lens 1 15% la
vraie c'est la rave révision obligatoire
pour tous 2000 24 24 est donc là on est
un peu long mais un peu loin c'est plus
ce poids-là quesnel blocage nous dans
notre esprit qu'on dirait visé en 2020
c'est pas pour les pays en développement
relève et s'est engagé sur c'est une
course grand public ne comprend pas
forcément comment ça fonctionne
exactement cet accord va sceller ce sont
les mystères effectivement de ce genre
de conférences de négociations
internationales mais l'important c'est
ce qu'il en sort finalement c'est pas
tellement la manière dont ça se passe
est de savoir si on y arrive et je crois
que c'est souvent l'objectif
certains y travaillent depuis des années
et là on est vraiment dans dans
l'extrême dernière ligne droite et donc
son sac on sent une grande grande
mobilisation une grande tension de la
part des négociateurs
mais demain 18h d'accord sincères et
vous en avez la proposition profond
à 18 heures ce qui sera fait le coup de
marteau laurent fabius il sera là c'est
toujours l'objectif
maintenant je suis pas deux heures près
si jamais fait en deux heures de plus
pour un accord ambitieux pour les prend
je veux dire que ça fait cinq ans qu'on
bosse là dessus là c'est le travail de
tous les pays puissent un camp qui se
joue dans cette dernière journée
alors on est pas c'est la dernière ligne
droite des négociations jusqu'au dernier
moment ronan dantec que veut faire
passer quelques mots dans le texte sur
les acteurs non étatiques tard dans la
soirée ils multiplient les réunions
informelles comme ici avec un
négociateur de l'union européenne mais c
est mon en fait on n'est plus très loin
de la cohérence mais on n'y est pas
encore c'est via l'union européenne
mon avis à venir à paris ce qui limite
leurs suggestions mais par contre
l'équipe française mais moi j'ai zappé
rien qu'il allait en l'allumant changé
peut-être on peut dire que s'est noyé
dans une texte
je tente le maroc
j'essayerai si je peux ne fait pas ces
messages mais
bach etc etc c'est un risque que l'union
européenne
dans le sprint final les négociations se
poursuivre toute la nuit pour venir à
bout des derniers points de friction en
marge du sommet à paris les
parlementaires du monde entier se
mobilise en grande pompe pour la coque
21 à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
une rencontre sans précédent par son
ampleur les délégations de près de 90
pays affluent pour cette conférence de
l'union interparlementaire uip et sur le
changement climatique
deux jours de marathon des dizaines
d'intervenants qui défilent dans
l'hémicycle
jusqu'au plus people comme l'ancien
gouverneur de californie
surnommé the governator arnold
schwarzenegger je suis au lit ici devant
nous pas en tant que n 1 de champion du
petit dédé du cinéma ou même en temps
l'ancien gouverneur de californie
je suis aujourd'hui en tant que citoyen
du monde les dames messieurs c'est là le
dessous de notre époque et c'est le
monde réel c'est pas le monde du cinéma
sinon toujours que je connais il n'y a
pas d'effets spéciaux ici il n'y a pas
de scénario qu'ils soient écrits ou de
changer la fin pour qu'elles soient
claires ça c'est le monde réel et il est
temps de choisir d'avoir un show prier
objectifs de ce sommet obtenir un
engagement des parlementaires du monde
entier dans la lutte contre le
changement climatique est une feuille de
route pour la ratification par les
parlements nationaux de l'accord qui
sera conclu à paris c'est le centriste
hervé maurey qui est chargé de rédiger
ce fameux texte
élaborée j'allais dire de manière assez
collégiale puisque
mois de juillet on y travaille depuis le
mois de juillet on reçoit des
amendements des différents pays membres
de l'uip est encore aujourd'hui c'est un
texte de consensus
qui devrait je pense de moi
ils vont être adoptées je l'espère en
tout cas
retour au bourget pour une nouvelle nuit
de négociations en perspective
c'est le moment crucial de cet accord il
ne reste que quelques heures pour
déterminer les ultimes compromis le vent
va-t-il tourner pour ronan dantec
va-t-il obtenir les quelques mots dont
il a besoin sur les acteurs non
étatiques déjà une nouvelle version du
texte vient de sortir l'avant dernière
le sénateur n'aura même pas le temps de
dîner
mais il ne perd pas son sens de l'humour
alors là tout a changé
tout a changé ce soir
j'ai pas encore une vision du texte
complet parce que là on a regardé plus
tôt les aspects juridiques on a regardé
effectivement les partis qui nous
intéressait mais j'ai quand même besoin
de voir le texte sur d'autres aspects
par exemple
son ambition général et sur lequel pour
l'instant j'ai l'impression que c'est
encore relativement faible donc je vais
prendre un peu le temps pour le lire
pour quand même
les consultations se poursuivent
jusqu'au petit matin dans les immenses
halls du bourget les délégations côtoie
la presse et la société civile
épuisée par dix jours de négociation
deuxième journée de rassemblement des
parlementaires au sénat cette fois les
représentants du monde entier déposent
leurs derniers amendements avant la
rédaction définitive du texte
les consultations se poursuivent jusqu'à
la dernière minute auprès d'hervé maurey
de gérard larcher et du président de
l'union interparlementaire
jusqu'au dernier moment on prend compte
des demandes qui arrive même si je
formellement dames on est en dehors des
délais le but étant qu'on arrive
vraiment une déclaration qui soit la
plus consensuelle possible
donc en parallèle de ce qui se passe
dans l'hémicycle et des interventions de
ce matin on était aussi sur ce travail
de préparation d'un déclaration qui sera
adoptée je l'espère ce soir un texte qui
n'a pas valeur de contrainte c'est
plutôt une boîte à outils pour
transposer l'accord trouvé par les chefs
d'états au bourget dans la juridiction
de chaque pays et invité les
parlementaires à aller plus loin encore
dans la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
il y avait un symbole plus fort on ne
saurait le trouver de voir ainsi les
parlements du monde entier les
parlementaires du monde entier
représentant les citoyens du monde
entier
être ici mobilisés pendant deux jours
pour que cette coop 21 trouve un nouvel
élan
car si les états sont toujours bloqués
dans les négociations le sénat lui veut
avancer c'est vrai qu'un certain nombre
de pays qui ont du mal à comprendre une
forme de contraintes internationales
mais on n'aura pas le choix à terme et
je pense que le sénat de la république
française en ayant parlé d' accord
contraignant prend ses responsabilités
des responsabilités que les
parlementaires aussi sont prêts à
prendre
voilà le quatrième larron
parmi les nombreux thèmes abordés dans
l'hémicycle la création d'un fonds vert
pour les pays les plus vulnérables
jérôme bignon veut approfondir ces
questions lors d'une réunion avec un
groupe de parlementaires francophones et
ce soit mais dont il faut des shows donc
donc c'est vraiment c'est là où habitent
des problématiques et des réponses très
différentes selon les pays certains
réclament la création d'un tribunal
spécial pour les crimes environnementaux
c'est une dépossession de la médoquine
c'est être juger les crimes contre à la
terre nous créions que nous croyons que
c'est le moment de prendre les
responsabilités réelles
ils les pays qui polluent le plus il
doit prendre ses responsabilités
une proposition qui ne sera pas retenu
mélanie il faut que cet accord ne soit
pas une entrave au développement
le gan au contraire inciter à un
investissement des finances publiques
aussi bien qu'un investissement privé
pour agir pour une économie verte pour
agir pour des ressources propres
malgré des intérêts divergents les
parlementaires du monde entier réunis en
séance au sénat par viennent d'adopter
une déclaration commune elle sera votée
en mars 2016 lors de la prochaine
réunion de l'uip et les parlementaires
ont donc réussi à imprimer leur marque
sur ce sommet de paris
mais pour hervé maurey pas question de
s'arrêter là leur rôle doit être enfin
reconnu à sa juste valeur dans les
négociations internationales
c'est nous qui ratifions c'est nous qui
votons les manger c'est nous qui votons
les lois sur lesquels un traité ne peut
pas avoir deux réalités
mais même dans la préparation
élaboration des des clopes à venir il
faut que les parlementaires soient
beaucoup plus associé parce que nous
amenons nous sommes un relais entre les
gouvernements et les opinions publiques
alors
les négociations de la conférence de
paris touchent à leur fin l'ultime
version du texte vient d'être publié
pour ronan dantec
ces deux semaines au bourget sont un
franc succès le sommet de nantes en
septembre 2016 est désormais inscrit
dans l'agenda international comme un
événement majeur pour les acteurs non
étatiques et cerise sur le gâteau le
texte reconnaît l'expérience de ses
acteurs et leur apporte les dispositifs
voulu pour travailler avec les états sur
la période 2015 2020
je dois considéré que les trois
objectifs sont atteints même
probablement mieux atteint que ce que je
n'osais espérait et si maintenant on a
en plus un accord universel ça aura été
qu un jour vraiment extrêmement
important extrêmement fructueux et même
si on est un peu fatigués c'est pas trés
ya un enthousiasme qu'il partage avec
les négociateurs du monde entier dans la
salle plénière du bourget sur le
président intervenant lors de la session
d'ouverture je m'exclame et trouver
l'accord
nous ferons le travail ce soir vous avez
trouvé l'accord est donc dès demain
c'est notre engagement nous nous
investirons dans l'action l'udaf and the
deal now we have to do the job merci
merci beaucoup à vous monsieur nantais
chers collègues et chefs
l'accord universal est sur la table le
texte est même plus ambitieux que
l'objectif initial de la coop 21
il prévoit de contenir le réchauffement
bien en dessous des 2 degrés celsius
et si possible à 1,5 degré ce texte qui
est nécessairement un texte équilibré
contient les principales avancées dont
beaucoup d'entre nous pensaient qu'elle
serait peut-être impossible à obtenir
l'accord de paris est acceptée
la france conservera la présidence de la
coop jusqu'à la conférence de marrakech
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
ratifieront officiellement l'accord de
paris le 22 avril 2016 au siège de l'onu
à new york
laurent fabius aura alors la charge de
l'adapter sous forme de projet de loi et
souhaite le transmettre au parlement
avant l'été 2016
hervé maurey et jérôme bignon ont
désormais toutes les clés pour le faire
voter au sénat
grâce à cet accord ronan dantec et les
acteurs non étatiques ont de nouvelles
cartes en main dans la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique